[Música]
en el 2009 apareció la cripta moneda
bitcoin que muy rápidamente transformó
la forma que realizamos todo tipo de
transacciones monetarias compras al por
menor inversiones en mercados
financieros y hasta compraventa de
bienes raíces y todo esto libre del
control regulatorio
un momento en verdad no estamos haciendo
nada de eso 12 años más tarde bitcoin y
otra escrito monedas juegan un papel
mínimo en la actividad económica mundial
y en el mundo de la tecnología 12 años
es una eternidad
yo obtuve mi primer trabajo programando
computadoras a finales del año 1980 y
dos años después tuve mi primera
experiencia con teletrabajo de una
oficina a otra
conectábamos una terminal a un equipo de
cómputo remoto usando módems conocidos
como acopladores acústicos en aquella
época que transmitían a 300 bits por
segundo
desde entonces en las cuatro décadas que
llevo trabajando con tecnologías de
información y comunicación novedosas
nunca había visto una tecnología nueva
rodeada de tanta hipérbole como bitcoin
y para mí todo ese height indica una
especie de brecha de credibilidad
vamos a ver la escrito monedas siendo
bitcoin la más conocida son un tipo de
dinero digital independientes de
cualquier banco central es decir que no
tienen el respaldo de un gobierno como
lo tiene cualquier dinero fiduciario
dinero fiat esta supuesta independencia
y anonimato en transacciones son
elementos que lo han hecho muy popular y
esto no es cualquier cosa porque por
primera vez en historia una persona
puede enviar cualquier cantidad de
dinero a otra persona en otra parte del
mundo en pocos minutos casi sin comisión
sin involucrar ni pedirle permiso a un
banco oa un ente regulatorio todas las
transacciones son tertsch bieber y son
anónimas
parte de esta brecha de credibilidad que
mencioné surge cuando que cuando se
habla del bitcoin muchas veces se
confunden y refunden de manera falaz dos
cosas distintas la primera que es
between como un medio de pago y la otra
que es bitcoin como un activo un camarín
en el cual se puede invertir en mercados
de divisas como en cualquier otro
camaret y de manera especulativa y
cuando hablamos de cripto monedas creo
que estamos usando el término equivocado
porque no son monedas sino me refiero
únicamente a que no son físicamente
tangibles la gente que estudia y escribe
sobre historia económica y política
monetaria dice que hay tres
características que definen una moneda o
clarence y tiene que ser una unidad de
cuenta tiene que ser un medio viable de
pago y tiene que ser un depósito de
valor estable con un poder adquisitivo
estable es decir que no se deprecia y
repentinamente y a mí me parece que
bitcoin como moneda nos satisface
ninguno de esos tres requerimientos
por otro lado si vamos a bitcoin como un
activo o un camarero en el cual se puede
invertir ahí es donde está el gran boom
boom y la locura especulativa es decir
para invertir yo compro bitcoin usando
dólares y espero que el futuro al precio
el bitcoin suba los vendo a cambio de
dólares y realizó una ganancia y sí que
es una locura porque la capitalización
de mercado de bitcoin es de más de 800
mil millones de dólares actualmente y no
sólo es bitcoin hay más de 1500 cripto
monedas que se transan de manera regular
en los mercados de divisas con una
capitalización de mercado total de 1.5
millones de millones de dólares
porque dije locura especulativa resulta
que el precio de bitcoin en el mercado
puede fluctuar hasta 30 por ciento en un
solo día de hecho en los últimos 12
meses ha fluctuado desde menos de 10 mil
dólares hasta casi 65 mil
sabiendo eso porque es que la gente está
dispuesta a pagar enormes sumas para
comprar activos que aparentemente no
hacen nada bueno la lógica es la misma
que se usa para comprar cualquier cámara
y los compradores piensan que los
precios van a subir
como suele suceder los inversionistas
iniciales siempre multiplican su dinero
de sus ganancias y atraen a nuevos
inversionistas si eso suena como burbuja
especulativa o tal vez un esquema de
estafa piramidal tipo ponzi porque
quizás si lo es
en los casinos la casa casi siempre gana
pero sabiendo eso millones de personas
van a jugar todos los días y
colectivamente pierden mucho más de lo
que ganan
todo este hype pero de hábito en conduce
a como firmes en out pero nadie está
obligado a entrar en el juego de bitcoin
y posiblemente terminar como este
personaje
dicen que bitcoin representa una
revolución en el sector financiero yo
veo una revolución ahí desde hace más de
una década y se llama fintech y poco
tiene que ver con cripto monedas las
aplicaciones de megino werning y otras
áreas de inteligencia artificial byc
deira y el internet de las cosas ha
impulsado innovaciones increíbles en
sistemas de pago servicios bancarios y
hasta la colocación de créditos por chip
y ver que se manejan todos desde el
celular hoy en día miles de millones de
transacciones se realizan en todo el
mundo de manera digital todos los días y
no tienen nada que ver con cripto
monedas además de los servicios usuales
que nos da la banca en línea en estados
unidos está paypal vendemos square deseo
en áfrica existe m-pesa desde hace años
para transferencias monetarias en china
tienen alipay y widget pay y aquí en
costa rica tenemos simple y simple móvil
todas esas son formas digitales de
manera de manejo de dinero pero no son
cripto monedas
en el que en el salvador a partir del
mes entrante se pueda usar bitcoin es
excelente noticia para las personas que
en total envían más de 5 mil millones de
dólares al año a sus parientes como
remesas eso es más o menos veintipico
por ciento el producto interno bruto no
es nada despreciable
actualmente los servicios de remesas así
el salvador son onerosos mientras que
con bitcoin yo puedo hacer una
transferencia en pocos minutos y casi
sin comisión
ojo que el problema entonces que bitcoin
va a resolver en el salvador no es un
problema de tecnología o de la moneda
per se sino de mercado el sistema
financiero internacional los bancos las
remiseras y swift básicamente ofrecen un
pésimo servicio a los usuarios que
quieren transferir cantidades
relativamente bajas de dinero de un país
a otro
la historia del mundo está repleta de
invenciones cuyas aplicaciones iniciales
tienen poca relación con sus usos
finales o incluso más impactantes el
transistor se inventó para amplificar
señales telefónicas y luego cambió el
mundo los tornillos de metal aparecieron
en el siglo 15 y ahora se usan hasta
para fijar tejido óseo estas son mis
vértebras cervicales hace unos años los
tornillos están aquí todavía
a inicios de los años 90 aquí en costa
rica una década después de haber
trabajado con el modo en que transmitía
300 bits por segundo yo lideré un
proyecto a nivel regional que ofrecía a
bajo costo servicio de correo
electrónico principalmente dirigido a
investigadores en las universidades
públicas y en las ongs de la región una
de las metas principales era ampliar el
uso del correo electrónico que hasta en
ese momento era inexistente o
inalcanzable entre investigadores de la
región y sus colegas afuera y eso sí se
logró pero el resultado más sorprendente
fue a través de esos cinco años fue ver
cómo se estrecharon los lazos entre las
personas dentro de la región
como dice el dicho uno nunca sabe para
quién o para que trabaja y esto me lleva
a pensar que tal vez la obsesión con
bitcoin tanto como medio de pago como un
activo sin respaldo y sin valor
intrínseco nos está distrayendo de dos
de sus innovaciones más brillantes la
primera el diseño y la implementación
del protocolo bitcoin que subyace a la
moneda demostró que sí es visa si es
viable usarla tecnología watch change
para aplicaciones reales en el mundo
aquí las aplicaciones de coaching fuera
del ámbito de la escrito monedas
prometen ser mucho más disruptivas a
mediano y largo plazo particularmente
como infraestructura de los llamados
contratos inteligentes
la segunda innovación es que bitcoin fue
diseñado desde el inicio para que el
trabajo de mantener y ser parte del
registro distribuido el llamado de
escribir y dwyer que componen la red de
bitcoin fuera recompensado con pequeños
y cada vez más escasos pagos del mismo
bitcoin
quizá bitcoin como moneda siga siendo
una solución en busca de un problema y
por su volatilidad nunca vaya a
suplantar el dinero fiduciario y que
termine siendo un artefacto más del
entorno financiero comercial del cual no
todo el mundo se haber beneficiado
siquiera afectado y puede que alguno de
los problemas que bitcoin si está
resolviendo hoy en particulares de
transferencias internacionales a bajo
costo y rápidas sean eventualmente
resueltas por el mercado utilizando las
tecnologías convencionales que ya
existen
en su libro the night world technology
el economista y polimat a brain ortiz
describe como las tecnologías
evolucionan
y explica su estructura recursiva es
decir qué tecnologías complicadas y
complejas están hechas por tecnologías
más sencillas y éstas a su vez más
sencillas y así sucesivamente
yo no tengo bola de cristal pero si
apuesto a que las tecnologías que
fundamentan y apuntalan las cripto
monedas van a engendrar y habilitar
otras tecnologías y servicios hasta
ahora inimaginables muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]